ma question c'est
espérons que les hôpital va redevenir
attractifs et que de nouveau les
infirmières postulent pour venir à
l'hôpital jusqu'où va-t-on en recruter
c'est à dire est ce qu'on va
revenir aux ratios qui était voilà et
pour ouvrir les lits équité en fait les
ratios copé remet au nom écrit sur le
papier non réglementaires ou est ce que
on va travailler sur des ratios plus
élevé je le dis parce que il ya un mot
vous n'avez pas prononcé alors que je
vous en êtes convaincus vous l'entendez
et nous l'avons entendu tout au cours de
ses auditions des soignants c'est la
crise de sens de leur métier et c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs les directeurs nous
ont dit aussi et encore à strasbourg que
malgré tout le monde convient que les
mesures du ségur sont des mesures
significatives en termes de
revalorisations personne met en cause ce
fait là mais de fait les soignants ne
revienne quand même pas à l'hôpital et
donc il ya évidemment d'autres sujets et
cette question de la crise du sens du
métier qui peut-être ne touche pas que
les soignants d'ailleurs ne touche pas
que l'hôpital
nécessite d'autres d'autres réponses et
que dans cette qualité dans la relation
que les soignants peuvent avoir parce
qu'on leur constitue un cadre de travail
adapté satisfaisant qui n'ont pas
l'assise la sensation d'être maltraitant
c'est une réponse qui est importante
encore il ya deux jours trois jours à
strasbourg où nous étions une infirmière
nous disait nous rappeler nous disait
mais moi j'avais une grande fierté
d'exercer mon métier
et maintenant elle ne sait pas que j'ai
plus de fierté mais quand même
je me sens plus ça va pas les conditions
dans lesquelles je travaille
je suis plus aussi heureuse aller au
travail le matin c'est un discours
récurrent et est ce dernier point et je
pense que vous pourrez pas répondre à
cette dernière remarque mais je vais
vous dire aussi que dans ces deux
auditions il ya une différence de
langage entre les soignants et les
institutions qui absolument marque en
jeu en toute humilité je ne sais pas
exactement quelle est la réponse mais il
ya un fossé qui est en train de se créer
ce n'est pas les mêmes mots qui sont
utilisés ce n'est pas le même langage à
utiliser ce n'est pas le même discours
qui est tenu et il ya vraiment on a
entendu d'un côté le discours des
soignants y compris des jeunes qui
décrivent l'hôpital comme un lieu de
violence institutionnelle qui ont des
mots très durs sur ce qu'ils vivent à
l'hôpital et c'est très inquiétant
l'ensemble des soignants et d'un autre
côté et je personnalise ray rien du tout
mais des institutions représentant
l'état de personnes qui sont
certainement très engagé au service du
bien public mais dont les discours dont
les
process pardon pour le terme là aussi je
dois utiliser un langage qui n'est pas
celui du quotidien mais est en décalage
total avec la réalité que décrivent les
soignants et peut-être qu'il ya aussi là
un fossé qui expliquent une part de la
crise de l'hôpital qui comme vous l'avez
dit ne se résoudra pas que par 9 des
apports de moyens financiers
je suis d'accord avec vous monsieur le
sénateur sur le différé le décalage de
discovery sont que je suis les deux
représentants d'institutions plus de
médecins hospitaliers puis j'ai beaucoup
travaillé avec j'ai occupé beaucoup de
fonctions de soins avant votre médecin
et c'est pas un discours qui est nouveau
la consternation que je comprends la
perte de sang j'ai pas parlé du mot
perte de sens mais j'ai tourné autour du
pot pendant tout son intervention
liminaire j'ai souvent j'ai souvent
parlé j'ai souvent parlé perte de sens
quand je vous dis recréer un service
donné un pouvoir décisionnel à l'équipe
lui donner un budget pour qu'ils
puissent investir dans son quotidien
regaud augmenter son salaire augmenter
le personnel autour de lui sortir la
logique administrative aux financières
lui enlever la pression de comptable de
la t2 en permanence sur ses épaules
revaloriser le la chargé à la permanence
des soins reconnaissent pas ces
spécificités lui permettre d'évoluer
dans ces mutins ses métiers ses
compétences je ne dit pas autre chose
que redonner du sens aux soignants
mais c'est si on fait rire une fois que
alors par contre entre l'annnonce de
quelque chose et la réalisation il ya du
temps ce que je veux dire c'est que ne
faisons pas et vous avez eu la
gentillesse et la loyauté de dire que le
ségur avait avait compté pour la feuille
de paye je vous faites moi confiance le
ségur ne joue pas que sur la feuille de
paye par contre les choses qui sont
visibles tout de suite à feuilles de
paye oui les choses qui prennent un peu
plus de temps et quand je vais dans un
hôpital annoncer qu'on va compte rires
refait complètement l'unité de soins
parce que les soignants sont exemple
d'avoir une salle de bain pour 22 malade
c'est pas le lendemain ils reviennent
travailler dans les mêmes conditions
parce qu'il faut trois à quatre ans pour
que les travaux puissent être faits même
si le budget est là donc c'est ce temps
là aussi qui est un temps incompressible
pour que le lien organisation interne
aux hôpitaux de changement de la
gouvernance soit visible par les
établissements c'est ça en fait la
question qui se pose c'est est ce qu'il
ya des éléments déterminants que nous
n'aurions pas mis en place qui se fait
petit de changer radicalement la donne à
très court terme je vous dis que ce qui
change la donne à très court terme c'est
déjà de mettre plus de personnel nous
d'en former davantage avec le ségur nous
avons proposé d'embauché 15000 soignants
supplémentaires et de remplir les postes
qui ne sont pas pourvus d'ouvrir quatre
milliers la demande pourquoi parce que
quand une infirmière elle est rappelée
chez elle le soir en lisant bah
finalement faut venir bosser demain il
week-end prochain fera venir bosser
aussi là il ya un sens un sentiment de
violence institutionnelle la personne
qui le rappelle n'est pas violente la
personne qui la rappelle à un planning
et n'arrivent pas à boucler et c'est là
que vous rentrez dans une spirale vous
mettez sous pression la personne et qui
a l'impression que finalement cette on
va la bouger d'un endroit à un autre
c'est d'autant plus vrai dans les très
grands hôpitaux un peu moins dans les
bus dans les hôpitaux plus petit donc
avoir une équipe qui est bien
dimensionné avec une bonne taille ça va
être la première décision que j'avais
pris comme ministre avant même que le
coït vraiment n'éclate j'avais réuni les
syndicats j'aurais dit écoutez moi il ya
un truc qui quand j'étais médecin
j'étais médecin peu de temps avant a
toujours énervé c'est quand on me disait
qu'il y aura un congé une infirmière qui
part en congé pendant 10 jours mais
quittera pas remplacés et je leur avais
dit plus aucun départ anticipable de
plus de 48 heures sans remplacement
ça fait partie des mesures du quotidien
qui compte vraiment ça fait partie de ce
qu'on appelle la cuve était la qualité
de vie au travail il ya aussi la
question des conflits c'est le sénateur
vous m'avez pas parler des conflits
monsieur président énormément de
conflits dans les équipes énormément de
conflit il faut pouvoir arriver à
apaiser les choses et donc et plus de
pression plus être conflit et plus être
conflit plus de pression ce que les gens
finissent par partir donc il faut vrai
véritablement faire ce travail pour
apaiser et sur la cuve était on a lancé
j'ai lancé un énorme chantier là aussi
qu'est ce qui s'est passé aussi l'année
dernière qui fait qu'ils aient eu une
réduction du nombre de soignants alors
même qu on augmente les salaires et
comme on essaie d'en embaucher plus
parce que pas mal de puteaux m'ont dit
c'est qu'il ya eu des départs qui ont
été différées des démissions de
soignants irait tous les ans avec ou
sans crise et les soignants ont dit on
va partir en pleine crise sanitaire on
décale stade 6 ou 12 mois est donc une
fois que la vague était passé entre
guillemets ce qui était devait partir et
qui avait que c'était de ne pas le faire
long feu il ya des renouvellement
d'effectif qui sont qui sont
insuffisants c'est pour ça qu'on
augmente fortement la formation c'est
pour ça aussi que je déploie avec un
minimum chanel apprentissage alternance
la vae j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure et
enfin ce qui est une crise des vocations
je regarde sur parcours super la
formation la plus demandée de notre pays
ces infirmières 687 mille demandes
d'information la deuxième formation la
plus demandée ces médecins 660 me le
demande je vous dis que si un problème
de vocation on le verrait à ce moment là
en revanche si elle est sortie et les
gens qui vont faire autre chose parce
que le métier est trop dure et qu'il ait
percuté et c est aussi le rapport du
travail post co vide qu'on voit dans la
restauration pour 20 dans l'entreprise
et qu'on voit évidemment à l'hôpital
travaille de nuit les week-ends avec des
gens qui sont fatigués qu'ils disent moi
je n'ai plus envie d'avoir une vie
consacrée à mon boulot jusque dans la
nuit les week-ends or il faut savoir que
quand on fait un métier du soin on bosse
la nuit les week-ends et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut pouvoir dire
aux jeunes quand ils s'inscrivent non
pas comme une fatalité mais parce que ça
fait partie de l'engagement surtout
quand on est dans le service public il
faut pouvoir le reconnaître ce travail
là évidemment faire en sorte qu'il soit
pas excessif il ya des choses qui sont
complètement déconnectés par exemple je
travaille avec les avec les internes où
il ya des heures qu'ils sont beaucoup
trop excessive et de la permanence de
soins qui est trop forte les gens
peuvent s'épuiser on a tous connu ça
quand on est passés par l'hôpital ça ce
sont des situations qu'on ne souhaite
plus avec frédéric vidal nous avons pris
l'engagement total de la tolérance zéro
sur toutes les dérives rencontrées par
les étudiants en santé l'amélioration de
l'accueil accéder à tout ce qui va
permettre de donner envie je crois que
tout cela c'est une c'est une réponse à
la crise de sens après interrogeons-nous
est-ce que nous sommes là face à une
situation franco-française personne ne
peut dire ça je crois que c'était ne pas
dire de bêtises mais je vais me semble
c'était la moitié des maternités qui
était quasiment en train de fermer en
suède l'angleterre fef a fait face la à
des difficultés de rh comme on en a
jamais eu et ils n'ont pas mis leur
place au ségur l'allemagne ministres
allemands disaient que c'est une
catastrophe dans les hôpitaux postes
postes kobe d'eau n'allons pas imaginer
qui est là aussi
un problème qui ne nous concerne vrai
que nous et après mais général des
crises évocation des soignants et il ya
eu de façon générale une temps d'une
tente une tentation de l'économie
persistante depuis une vingtaine
d'années à peu près dans toutes les tous
les pays de ces oeufs
je vais passer à part à mes collègues
prochaine réponse si vous pouviez nous
redit ramos dans les ratios mais
peut-être une réponse je voulais jouer
pension du ratio pardonnez moi je lui
réponds là dessus très bien bravo ratio
d'avant je sortirai la logique des
ratios non moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on
sorte de la logique des ratios ce qu'il
faut c'est qu'on fasse c'est qu'on
confie aux établissements et aux yeux et
aux équipes l'unité le soin de d'évaluer
localement les charges en soins le ratio
ça peut être un garde-fou entre
guillemets qui nous assure qu'il ait pas
trop de pression sanitaires sur quelques
soignant mais en réalité si vous donner
suffisamment de moyens à une équipe en
lui disant qu'elle peut s'organiser et
tenir compte de la réalité de chaque
unité hospitalière à mon avis c'est une
meilleure garantie de qualité prise en
charge et les endroits dans lesquels
c'est nécessaire et d'ailleurs il existe
dans le droit mais je crois pas qu'il
faille qu'on tende je crois pas qu'il
faille tendent vers absolument temps
pourtant je crois qu'il faut dire par
contre tant de moyens pourtant
[Musique]